for that another fox news alert
meanwhile in capitol hill where the
house budget committee is putting the
finishing touches
on president biden's nearly two trillion
dollar coveted relief bill
democrats aiming for a full house vote
by the end of the week we have complete
coverage for you
for you former white house
communications director alyssa farah
will join us in moments but we begin
with chief congressional correspondent
mike emanuel he's live on the hill for
us so mike
what are republicans saying about this
so far
it's andrew good afternoon it's a nearly
600 600-page bill including what some
republicans are calling
a long list of liberal priorities 350
billion dollars for state and local
governments
35 billion dollars for subsidies to pay
obamacare premiums
30 billion dollars for public transit
agencies
and a billion dollars plus for socially
disadvantaged farmers
a leading house democrat told me he
would like there to be at least some
bipartisan support let's come together
as republicans and democrats
and get it done i totally agree with
with president biden i'd really like to
see republican buy-in on this
it also includes boosting the federal
minimum wage which leading republicans
know could hurt companies
already struggling during the pandemic
the 15 minimum wage what does that have
to do with covet relief those small
businesses
are going to have an even harder time
coming back when you go to a 15
minimum wage these things have nothing
to do with covid
it sounds like that minimum wage height
could get stripped out in the senate due
to the rules there or perhaps due to a
lack of support
but as it stands it's in the bill being
considered by the house
this week sandra okay mike emanuel on
the hill for us mike thank you
john sandra thank you for more on what's
included in this massive covid relief
bill
let's bring in former white house
communications director alyssa farah
listen good to see you today let's uh
put up
what i thought was an interesting
excerpt from a wall street journal
editorial about all of this it said
quote
no wonder democrats want to pass all
this on a partisan vote it's a
progressive
blowout for the ages that does little
for the economy but will finance
democratic interest groups for years
please don't call it covid relief but
the democrats are insisting
hey you've got to go big you can't
undershoot because it's more danger to
do that than it is to overshoot
well john great to be with you and i
couldn't agree more with the wall street
journal editorial there
keep in mind just a matter of a few
weeks ago president biden promised that
he wanted to govern
on a bipartisan basis he wanted to be a
president for all americans
yet he is now trying to ram through the
biggest stimulus in history nearly two
trillion dollars
without any republican support at this
time and i would note because you and i
were both at the white house
during the trump administration we were
able to pass
four previous cares coveted relief bills
under uh with bipartisan support
when you're talking about something of
this magnitude you need to make sure
that it has buy-in from both sides
and i'd also note that only about 10 of
this relief package
actually goes toward public health this
is a liberal wish list
that is meant to benefit democrats and
their progressive support
in particular states this is not coveted
relief
this wall street journal op-ed breaks it
all down in terms of its spending now
obviously there is some spending
for coronavirus and and for health as
you pointed out but there's a lot of
spending that's not in this according to
the editorial
all told the generous definition of
covid related provisions
tallied some 825 billion the rest of the
bill more than a trillion dollars
is a combination of bailouts for
democratic constituencies expansions of
progressive programs
port and unrelated policy changes some
of the more controversial
progressive wish list items are federal
minimum wage of fifteen dollars an hour
270 million dollars in arts and
humanities endowments 200 million from
museums and libraries
50 million in family planning uh funding
and 112 million dollars for bay area
rapid transit there's also
one and a half million dollars for a
bridge that connects the united states
new york state
with canada up near cornwall ontario not
far from where i grew up i know that
that's a chuck schumer
uh plum but what does that have to do
with coronavirus
oh nothing and i would add to this
there's still about 64 billion dollars
in congressionally appropriated funding
for covid relief that has yet to be
spent by congress this
is about pushing through democrat
priorities under the guise of covet
relief
nearly every republican supports the top
lines of it direct payments to
americans unemployment insurance
extension and ppp
it's when you tack on these you know the
massive spending editions in it that
have nothing to do with the coronavirus
that you're going to lose republican
support alyssa you mentioned money from
the last coronavirus bill that has not
yet been spent that includes about 113
billion dollars for schools
there's a lot of new money for schools
in this 1.9 trillion dollar measure but
that money is earmarked to not be spent
until 2022 to 2028 after the pandemic
we believe will be over well absolutely
and white house press secretary jen
sachi wouldn't even commit to the fact
that this
additional money for schools would be
committed to schools that are actually
reopen and actually doing in-person
classes
so it raises the question what even is
the need for these billions of dollars
in additional school funding
if it doesn't even require that you're
having in-person education
well it looks like the democrats are
going to try to put this through the
house
on a bike on a partisan basis and then
try to do the same thing in the senate
we'll see though
if that holds up because there are a
couple of democrats who have said
that they're not particularly fond of
this bill so we'll see how it goes
alyssa farah as always great to see you
thanks thanks john